what can we learn from this don't make a
movie in North Korea and don't cave in
utterly and so that you can't even make
lemonade out of lemons out of this I
think the there's a couple key lessons
we can take from it one is obviously
enough take cybersecurity seriously in
this situation sony has been repeatedly
hot going back at least to 2005 and yet
the way by all reports this group got in
wasn't with incredibly advanced
techniques it was kind of the cyber
equivalent of a crude pipe bomb the
other part is don't just think that your
exterior line of defense is enough it
doesn't work for eggs it doesn't work
for major corporations and it's really i
think shocking the way that once they
got inside it was as if they had the
keys to the kingdom they had access to
you know everything from the gossipy
emails that have made so much news to
financial information to legal
information a lot of this stuff should
have been kept separate and encrypted
and third it points to the way that you
personally operate both as a just
private citizen to a business executive
the way these people within the firm
were emailing to each other it was like
they'd never been on email before they
were you know bad-mouthing business
partners other people and you know this
is your mom teaches you not to do this
but also you know everyone from Enron to
Goldman Sachs has paid a legal and
financial price for the kind of things
they put what they thought was in
private email guess what emails not
going to be private in these days and
you have to act responsibly that way Mia
what have you learned wedding yeah so
thematically when I've been speaking to
analysts yesterday they said you should
identify your crown jewel so I see your
finger you've got some nice bling on
your finger you know where your crown
jewels are you probably have a safe at
home with your jewelry as well you know
the most important things that are that
are for you and you know where to hide
them I know where my jewels are why does
sony not know where their scripts are
where their passwords are their employee
insurance plans they should have those
in safe places online and also in the
physical world as well and they should
have those places constantly changing so
that that's not in the same area ever
time but Peter is this in the case of
the fact that we have gone online and
become digital over the last few years
and no one's prepared if you think about
who works in IT departments at any sort
of company and I'm gonna guess a movie
studio would be one those people and IT
don't get paid very much they probably
don't even get a lot of respect in the
company well I want to echo the point
that was made earlier though there's a
lesson here that again applies whether
it's in the physical world or in the
cyber world if you can't bear to lose
something prepare to lose it right and
that applies to whether it's your birth
certificate or your electronic crown
jewels now to the point that you are
making the word the theme we should be
thinking about here whether it's the
nation in our cybersecurity your own
cyber security or fortune 500 business
private security it's not just about
defense it's about resilience and what
I'm getting at here is that even if you
have some of the best cyber security
people working for you if they're honest
they're going to tell you I can't
promise you one hundred percent security
at some point the bad guy is going to
get in they may already be on the inside
the US military for example its biggest
troubles have been insider attacks you
know Manning or Snowden and so the key
is not keeping yourself one hundred
percent secure because it's never going
to happen it's how do I power through
the attack how do I get back up quickly
when I'm knocked down and then now we
have a third lesson from Sony and the
movie theaters which is how do I not
cave in give the attackers everything
that they wanted more incentivizing
every other attacker in the world to
come after the problem also stephanie is
when you think about an IT manager
they're not incentivized to have a good
ROI they can't go out to a trade show
and figure out you know which security
system they want to buy and then make
the case to their CTO saying hey if i
buy this top of the end system it's
going to prevent 1 billion dollars of
trade secrets from exiting our system
they can't do that they don't know how
to spend that marginal security dollar
because they can't make a good business
case for it and so ultimately many of
them have been saying why don't we just
wait till after the security breach
happens and deal with it then rather
than investing all the money upfront and
having to protect it which isn't always
the right mindset
aren't companies like Sony now going to
lose and or spend so much money after
the fact when it was when it was
preventable before but more costly
before perhaps in Franklin sorry Peter
Ben Franklin saying about an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure you
know it applies in this space and one of
the things that matters here as well is
how we measure the cost of a cyber
attack which then shapes what we're
willing to spend to prevent it and so
far businesses if typically when they
think about the potential cost of an
attack they think about how much time
I'm going to be knocked offline and then
the cleanup costs whether its technical
or legal but as we're seeing from
whether it's the target breach or this
case was Sony there's all sorts of other
costs that kick in it's everything from
impact on your brand to your customers
being upset with you your business
partners and it's interesting there was
a survey taken of over 500 business
executives and when they ask them what's
the cost of a cyber attack only
thirty-nine percent of them Wade impact
on brand only twenty five percent weight
impact on lost intellectual property and
that's just the wrong way to go about
thinking about it well I just want to
share their some breaking news we've
seen Reuters is reporting that the
United States is officially making this
statement North Korea is responsible for
the cyberattack so seeing that they're
making a statement like that how do you
think we should react suddenly it's not
just a bunch of hackers we can't I mean
this is official Peter the challenge
here the challenge here is that in these
incidents everyone wants to focus on
attribution who did it to me and the
real problem is accountability what am I
going to do back to them so that they
don't either to punish them and or to
prevent them from doing this in the
future and now when you talk about North
Korea it takes it from being a cyber
incident to the problem in North Korea
in general which is you know they've
done everything from nuclear test
nuclear proliferation
to you know there's been incidents where
they've killed they sank a close ally
ship and killed 46 of their sailors just
a couple years ago so it's not like we
had good relations with North Korea
before it's not like we weren't trying
to sanction their economy before and so
you know this is not an act of war in
terms of we're not going to go to war
over this and now we're looking for
other tools the problem is when you're
talking about North Korea we've been
using most of the tools already so it's
not a cyber problem now it's a North
Korea problem in general Mia do you
believe from the analysts you've spoken
to this could change the way companies
behave companies have to focus on the
bottom line they have shareholders to
answer to so when those IT professionals
have been asking them to make the big
spend they simply can't they're saying I
got other fish to fry something like
this especially now that it has become
this serious could we start to see a
shift you know one analyst his name is
Jonathan Bernstein he's a crisis manager
he says he anticipates companies to
spend more money not an IT systems but
on crisis management because it's just
easier and less expensive to put your
dollars on it afterwards rather than
forehead you just saw how awful that is
for a company like Sony to have to deal
with that they're willing to take the
brand hit they're willing to take that
reputational hit because from a cost
point of view it's just too expensive to
take care and ensure that you have all
the right cyber walls in place to
prevent an attack that might happen
point zero one percent chance that it
could happen but is it too expensive
Peter because yes maybe it's a point
zero one chance but if it happens it
could take you down I I would disagree
with you know both parts of the premise
the first is the idea of it being a
point zero one or any kind of low level
the reality is of the top 500 companies
in the world ninety-seven percent of
them have admitted they've been hacked
at some point and the other three
percent have been too they just haven't
admitted it and that's true whether
you're talking about large companies all
the way down to you know small cupcakes
if you are online you will deal with
cyber threats it's just simply a reality
and then the other part is as we were
talking about before is the nature of
the cost it's just a lot more of
effective to focus on preventing and
being resilient to the attacks then
focusing on the clean up afterwards and
that's true again whether you're talking
about anything from cyberattacks to you
know the same argument can be said about
fire or theft in general so again if
people think the their way out of this
is to hire crisis management or good PR
they're setting themselves up for a
world of hurt